today we will see how nvidia's new AI
sends these little virtual soldiers to
camp and teaches them how to fight this
is a follow-up work to an absolutely
amazing paper called ASE this is a
previous work with little AI soldiers
that trained for 10 years 10 years how
well 10 years of their in-game world
that is which is fortunately when using
a fast machine is only 10 days in our
time and they learned a great deal they
went from a bunch of sorry little
recruits to battle-ready soldiers except
this chap this chap goes like sir I've
been training for two years I've had
enough and now I shall live in style and
in this new work these little soldiers
trained for 5 billion training steps on
a single graphics card it's not a cheap
one but still a single graphics card so
what do we get for these 5 billion
training steps can this new one do
anything better than the previous one
well first it can learn from unlabeled
motion capture data what is that well a
bunch of dots moving that represents
movement of real humans that have been
recorded and now step number one basic
training here the moving dots go in and
a neural network is asked to create
motions that are similar to it so are we
done well not quite you see we wish to
use this in video games and this is not
controllable yet imagine a video game
where you press a button on the
controller and nothing happens so now
comes step number two Precision training
here it now needs to perform the
movements but also listen to our
controls especially when we use the
stick to steer it in different
directions and step number three here we
not only give it directions but
intuitive commands as well such as
striking or running all that is great
but what can you do now well let's see
together for instance it can interpolate
between two movement types this means
that it works like a gymnast who has
perfected a difficult routine it can't
jump straight from one move to another
it needs to trans position smoothly to
maintain balance and perform the routine
successfully thus it first starts
running and then lock it gradually
dreams up a smooth transition from
sprinting to crouching that is a really
nice and believable transition I love it
and now comes the best part hold on to
your papers fellow Scholars because now
you'll see how it can do these types of
transitions on demand that means as a
reaction to our button meshing on the
controller
so good however not even this technique
is perfect it still has some issues to
be worked out for instance check this
out now little AI move towards the
target attack great and now celebrate
whoa careful moments like this show that
this work is still experimental I don't
think you will see this in a new game
tomorrow but this is what research is
about taking something highly
unstructured and using learning based
techniques to create something useful
from it now wait a second in the intro I
also said that this is a follow-up to
the ASE paper so how does it compare to
that one
oh my are you seeing what I am seeing
because I am seeing two excellent news
here now I hear you asking okay Doctor
what are the excellent news here well
one let's start with the most obvious
one the controllability of the
simulation has improved Leaps and Bounds
that is incredible and second what is
even more incredible this
controllability did not come at the
expense of the diversity of the moveset
that is perhaps the best part of the
paper you see this is in a class of
neural network based techniques that
often suffer from a phenomenon called
mode collapse what is mode collapse well
imagine asking a gymnast to perform
incredible acrobatics and this gymnast
can do a variety of things but
unfortunately just keeps doing the same
thing over and over again card two years
all day every day imagine looking at an
Olympic gold medal athlete who just
keeps doing those cartwheels and it is
not the case here this is an athlete
that can do everything I absolutely love
this Bravo what a time to be alive and
finally some fantastic news for the end
the source code of this project is
available I would like to send a big
thank you to the scientists on this
project making it available for all of
us free of charge and for now let the
experiments begin if you are looking for
inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now
offers the best prices in the world for
GPU Cloud compute no commitment or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with the Lambda GPU Cloud
you can now get on demand h100 instances
for just 199 per hour yes 199 and they
are one of the first Cloud providers to
offer publicly available on-demand h100
XS did I mention they also offer
persistent storage so join researchers
at organizations like apple MIT and
Caltech in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lambdalabs.com papers to sign up for
one of their amazing GPU instances today
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time